hello in this video we'll talk about the
froster resonance energy transfer or
fret
so in this video we'll talk about the
principles behind frit the applications
and the limitations of freight so stay
tuned and don't forget to subscribe and
hit that bell icon
fluorescence resonance energy transfer
is a mechanism
where the energy gets transferred from
one particular fluorophore which is
known as the donor to the acceptor
provided this donor and acceptor
are within a particular close proximity
so here the donor is excited by a
wavelength of light
and
the energy gets quickly transferred to
the acceptor and then the acceptor
starts fluorescing and this phenomenon
is known as fret
now first of all we should understand
that fret is a non-radiative energy
transfer and it happens due to
non-radiative dipole-dipole coupling
so fret happens when these
fluorophores are at very close proximity
at a distance roughly below than 10
nanometers
but when the distance between these
molecules are greater than 10 nanometer
or more
then fret is not possible
so let's try to understand
uh that what are the key factor that
helps
in the process of fret
so fret is a function of distance if the
distance increase fret would not happen
and the efficiency of fret can be
expressed by this formula e equal to 1
by 1 plus r by r 0
where small r is the distance between
two chloroform molecules and r 0 is a
quantity
that is characteristic distance
where the freight efficiency is 50
and it's also a function of what type of
freight sensors we are using or the
fluorophore couples that we are using
now if you try to understand this from a
graphical point of view we can see the
graph looks like this
so with the increase in
the
distance between two molecules
the fret would be diminished
or there would be almost no fret
and the r0 is a property of the fuel
donor and acceptor pair for example if
we use the cyan fluorescence protein and
yellow fluorescence protein pair then
the r0 would be roughly around
4.72 nanometers
now let's try to understand the
zablonski diagram and the
excitation and emission spectrum
for freight
so here is the excitation wavelength
so obviously the electrons would jump up
to a higher excitation state
then it should be a emission
in a like radiative fashion
but when the two molecules are close
proximity there would be a fret transfer
and thereby
the fluorescence would be
observed at a very high wavelength in
this case the wavelength is would be
corresponding to yfp
and we have stimulated the cyan
fluorescence protein and we are getting
a fluorescence corresponding to
the yellow fluorescence protein so this
is how we can understand the fret
diagram or the zablonski diagram for
freight
now let's talk about how freight is done
in the lab
so in order to do fret we need to
express the freight constructs inside
our cell or tissue
let's say we want to study a protein
protein interaction using fret acid so
we have expressed protein a with
the cyan blue resin protein and
protein b with yellow fluorescence
protein and then we have transfected
both these expression plasmid
into
a cultured cell
now obviously these expression plasmid
would be expressed inside these cells
and they would generate the proteins or
the fret constructs
then using a fluorescence microscope we
can image fret in real time
so fret based calcium sensors are
frequently used by
here
we excite with a wavelength of 440
nanometers and in this fret sensor you
have a calmodulin module moiety coupled
with the m13 helix and the
acceptor and donor pair
here we have excited the acceptor with
440 nanometer wavelength light
now these as you can see in this image
these two acceptor and donor pair are
pretty far apart so fret is not possible
between them
thereby the emission would be at 475
nanometer and we would get a emission
correspond to the cyan fluorescence
protein
but
when calcium is present there would be a
conformational change which would bring
this m13 helix
in a way that the cfp and the yfp come
very close to each other
and under these circumstances if we
further excite
the cfp with 440 nanometer now instead
of getting a fluorescent at
475 nanometer we are going to get a
fluorescence at 530 nanometer correspond
to the yfp fluorescence that means fret
occurred in this case because the two
fluorophores are in close proximity
so in simple words we can understand
in absence of calcium there would be no
fret but in presence of calcium there
would be fret
and this
change would tell us about the presence
of calcium in the cell
so
using this strategy neuroscientist can
really understand the calcium
oscillations inside the neurons
let's take another example
these thread based sensors can be also
useful to study signaling pathways how
is that so we are looking at the cyclic
amp sensor in this case
we have excited with 440 nanometer and
there is fret happening
because these two fluorophores are very
close to each other
notice that in this case without even
binding the cyclic amp the freight is
happening but what really happens when
cyclic amp is bound when cyclic amp is
bound these there is a conformational
change which results in this particular
fluoro force to separate out from each
other and the distance between them
really increases
and in that case if we excite the cfp
with 440 nanometer we are going to get a
fluorescence at 475 instead of 530
nanometer that means
only the donor would show fluorescence
now the acceptor is not showing any kind
of fluorescence in this case that simply
means fret didn't happen
so no freight in this case means
there is presence of cyclic amp so we
can get
both these scenarios that we have
discussed so far either the presence of
freight or the
absence of freight both can tell us
about something
now this is a
quite reversible process in this case so
let's try to contextualize in a
signaling perspective we can understand
what really happens in g protein coupled
receptor signaling when
ligand binds
the g alpha subunit gets dissociated and
it it's bound to gtp which activates the
adenylate cyclase which leads to cyclic
amp production production of cyclic amp
could be taken as a readout for this
signaling and downstream events would
happen
therefore
so the cyclic amp
fret sensor can tell us about the
activity status of the signaling pathway
so when the ligand is absent and the
pathway is not active
then there would be fret
but
when the pathway is active the ligand is
present that means the cyclic amp is
generated in presence of cyclic amp
there would be no fret
so presence or absence of
freight tells us about the on and off
status of this particular signaling
pathway
so that's amazing so it's especially
attractive to cell biologists because
they can understand the output of a
signaling pathway or the readout of a
signaling pathway and they can measure
it in a real time it's a quantitative
measurement
now let's talk about the limitations of
fret there are tons of limitations of
freight first of all the donor and
acceptor fluorophore might exhibit
different change in the different level
of brightness
and that could
lead to a error in the measurement
there could be also
bleed through which would lead to a
fault in the freight measurement
the time resolution is limited by the
frame rate of the camera that would be
used to measure fret so temporal
resolution is always an issue
photo bleaching and also requirement of
special modifications of a microscope
like specific uh
fluorescence filter is also a kind of
limitation of this first fret asset
despite of this limitation what we
what we understand from this video is
that fret is a really important
tool in case of cellular and molecular
biology to understand protein protein
and
protein protein interaction
sometime it can also report the
signaling output or presence of a
particular
molecule like calcium in the cell so it
can be a bio biological sensor it can be
a signaling measurement readout it can
also tell us about the interaction or
the proximity of two proteins
so i hope this video was useful
you can get all the notes and flash
cards in the facebook page the link of
the facebook page is provided in the
description so don't forget to follow
that
and as usual don't forget to like share
and subscribe do let me know in the
comment whether you like my videos or
not
you can support my channel in patreon
and if you're an indian viewer you can
support me via bimupi app my courses are
also present in academy which is india's
online learning platform it's the
biggest learning platform by using my
code ap10 you can get a 10 discount in
that thanks for listening see you in the
next video